[Música]
este próximo primero de octubre se
celebran cinco años del referendo
independentista en Cataluña que llevó a
la encarcelación de varios líderes
independentistas además una votación que
a pesar de contar con amplio apoyo
Popular en la región no fue reconocida
por Madrid Carles puigdemont el ex
presidente de la generalitat de Cataluña
eh digamos hace cinco años Tuvo que
exiliarse por todos estos hechos en
Bélgica ante lo ocurrido vamos a
analizarlo con Jordi Muñoz o profesor de
ciencia política en la universidad de
Barcelona y director del centro de
estudios de opinión Jordi Gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 tras 5 años de este referendo
le pregunto si se ha pagado el
movimiento que llenó las calles el
primero de octubre de 2017
bueno Es evidente que no estamos en un
momento de tanta movilización social en
Cataluña y creo que además en general
después de la pandemia en la mayoría de
los países las protestas en la calle
fueron hacia abajo y Cataluña en este
sentido no es una excepción este seguro
que no es el único factor pero es un
factor importante aún así cabe decir que
hace unas semanas el 11 de septiembre
hubo una manifestación de dimensiones
importantes en Barcelona es decir que la
la protesta la movilización ha
disminuido pero no ha desaparecido claro
digamos que peseaste mal estado de ánimo
que pueda haber entre las personas
independentistas en el día de Cataluña
por ejemplo el 11 de septiembre salieron
cientos de personas a las calles miles
de personas a las calles y yo lo quiero
preguntar si con esto se está creando
digamos algún tipo de caldo de cultivo a
la espera de nuevos liderazgos o
políticos como en el momento tuvo Carles
puigdemont
Bueno hay que tener en cuenta que si
miramos tanto en los votos como en las
encuestas el apoyo de la independencia
se mantienen niveles muy altos son quizá
un poco más bajos que en el momento
álgido digamos de la del problema hace
cinco años pero se mantienen en unos
niveles superiores al 40%, los partidos
independentistas en las últimas
elecciones hace un año obtuvieron el 52%
de los votos es decir que el apoyo
social a la idea se mantienen niveles
muy altos han bajado un poco pero siguen
siendo muy altos Comparado con la
historia de movimiento en Cataluña y por
lo tanto aunque no se exprese de manera
tan explícita o tan determinada las
calles en forma de protestas o en forma
de movilizaciones Sigue estando ahí
porque en el fondo el problema de fondo
digamos de la relación entre Cataluña y
España no se ha solucionado
lo que lo que sí cierto Jordi es que hay
digamos en actualidad disputas en el
gobierno de proindependencia de Cataluña
la centro derecha acusa digamos a la
centro izquierda de estar yendo en
contra de la voluntad del pueblo del
primero de octubre esta nueva generación
de políticos ha cambiado de alguna
manera el discurso
Bueno hay diferencias estratégicas
importantes entre los partidos
independentistas Los partidarios de la
independencia en Cataluña están
divididos en varios partidos o algunos
más de izquierdas otros de Centro
izquierda otros de Centro O quizá de
centro de derecha como decía usted y
tienen estrategias y planteamientos
diferentes en estos días hay una crisis
de gobierno que no sabemos cómo
terminará entre los entre los socios y
esto ciertamente
puede afectar al estado de ánimo digamos
también del electorado y del movimiento
claro el pasado el primero de octubre
2017 cuando se hizo el referendo la
mitad de los líderes de ese momento fue
encarcelada la otra mitad digamos se fue
a exiliar a Bélgica como lo hizo el
presidente de la generalitat
raspuchamont costos políticos que tuvo
la respuesta del Estado español
Bueno
realmente creo que la respuesta del
Estado español en forma de eso de
encarcelamiento o de amenazas
encarcelamiento que provocó el exilio de
otros líderes genera un rechazo fuerte
en la opinión pública catalana si
miramos los datos de encuestas Desde
aquel momento el rechazo fue fuerte
después de la sentencias contra los
líderes políticos catalanes hubo unas
movilizaciones muy intensas en 2019 en
Cataluña muy amplias durante muchos días
y creo que todo esto son factores que
llevaron al gobierno español por ejemplo
a hace poco más de un año a indultar a
los líderes independentistas que estaban
en que estaban en prisión no y permitir
que salieran de prisión con el objetivo
de
disminuir la tensión y de intentar
entiendo superar la El Fuerte rechazo
que había provocado estos
encarcelamientos en la sociedad de
catalana sigue habiendo el problema no
resuelto de las personas que están en el
exilio en Bélgica o en Suiza en el caso
de Marta rovira y esto es un problema
que
seguramente impide que se afronten los
problemas digamos políticos de fondo
mientras allá esta carpeta encima de la
mesa Jordi precisamente quería hablar de
esos indultos que se firmaron o con el
gobierno del presidente del gobierno
español El socialista Pedro Sánchez
digamos que de alguna manera Está mejor
la relación ahorita entre Madrid y
Barcelona
Bueno hay un proceso de negociación una
mesa de negociación entre el gobierno
Catalán y el gobierno español que fue
fruto de un acuerdo de investidura que
permitía Pedro Sánchez ser presidente
con los votos de diputados
independentistas en Madrid y este
proceso de negociación en el marco de
este proceso de negociación hay
ciertamente una cierta normalización de
las relaciones aún así
los frutos de este proceso de
negociación cuestan de ver son lentos y
hay mucha disputa también dentro del
campo independentista y dentro de los
partidos españoles sobre si es
conveniente mantener este proceso de
negociación o darlo por finalizado visto
que los resultados no son buenos por lo
tanto yo diría que ahora mismo Está
encima de la mesa la negociación el
diálogo político
dentro de un año y nos volvemos a ver no
sé si Seguiremos en este escenario muy
rápidamente Antes de antes de despedirlo
posibilidad real de una independencia de
Cataluña de España en los próximos años
30 segundos
Bueno yo creo que eso es una es una
pregunta que cuando la hacemos en las
encuestas a la opinión pública la gente
tiende a verlo como muy difícil porque
realmente hay pocos antecedentes de
independencias en contextos europeos
democráticos estados estables etcétera
etcétera no y por lo tanto es un
objetivo que se ve difícil Ahora tiene
unos niveles de apoyo muy importantes
por encima del 40% en estos momentos en
la opinión pública catalana y por lo
tanto no diría que es imposible